Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow
of death, I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning. Good morning.
My name is Alan Rice
and I'm one of your elders here in the church.
My sermon title for the day is,
which Way Are You Headed?
I have the honor of preaching on the second longest Psalm
out of all 150.
I covered your prayers this morning
because I have a sore throat
and we'll see if my voice gets to the end of it.
It is a Psalm 78 is a stunning 72 verses long.
I'd like to start out this morning
by reading the entire Psalm out loud so we can take in
what I consider its epic grander.
Then I'll give you my first reaction to it.
Psalm 78, A MA skill of asap.
Give ear on my people to my teaching
and Kline your ears to the words of my mouth.
I will open my mouth in a parable.
I will utter dark things from of old things
that we have heard and known that our fathers have told us.
We will not hide them from their children,
but tell to the coming generation the glorious deeds
of the Lord and his might
and the wonders that he has done.
He established a testimony in Jacob
and appointed a law in Israel which he commanded our fathers
to teach to their children
that the next generation might know them, their children
yet unborn and arise
and tell them to their children so
that they should set their hope in God
and not forget the works of God but keep his commandments
and that they should not be like their fathers.
A stubborn and rebellious generation,
a generation whose heart was not steadfast,
whose spirit was not faithful to God.
The mites armed
with a bow turned back on the day of battle.
They did not keep God's covenant
but refused to walk according to his law.
They forgot his works
and the wonders that he had shown them
in the sight of their fathers.
He performed wonders in the lands
of Egypt in the fields of Zan.
He divided the sea and let them pass through it
and made the water stand like a heap.
In the daytime He led them with a cloud
and all the night with a fiery light,
he split rocks in the wilderness
and gave them drink abundantly.
As from the deep, he made streams come out of the rock
and caused waters to flow down like rivers.
Yet they sinned still more against him,
rebellion against the most high in the desert.
They tested God in their heart by demanding the food
they craved.
They spoke against God saying, can God
spread a table in the wilderness?
He struck the rock so that water gushed out
and streams overflowed.
Can he also give bread or provide meat for his people?
Therefore, when the Lord heard he was full of wrath,
a fire was kindled against Jacob.
His anger rose against Israel
because they did not believe in God
and did not trust his saving power.
Yet he commanded the skies above
and opened the doors of heaven
and he rained down on them manna to eat
and gave them the grain of heaven.
Man ate the bread of the angels.
He sent them food in abundance.
He caused the east wind to blow in the heavens
and by his power he let out the south wind.
He reigned meat on them like dust,
weaned birds like the sand of the seas.
He let them fall in the midst of their camp all
around their dwellings and they ate
and were filled for.
He gave them what they craved, but
before they had satisfied their craving,
while the food was still in their mouths, the anger
of God rose against them and he killed the strongest of them
and laid low The young men of Israel.
In spite of all this, they still sinned.
Despite his wonders they did not believe so.
He made their days vanish like a breath
and their years and terror.
When he killed him, they sought him.
They repented and sought God earnestly.
They remember that God was their rock, the most high God,
their redeemer, but they flattered him with their mouths.
They lied to him with their tongues.
Their heart was not steadfast toward him.
They were not faithful to his covenant.
Yet he being compassionate, atone for their iniquity
and did not destroy them.
He restrained his anger often
and did not stir up all his wrath.
He remembered they were
but flesh a win that passes
and comes not again.
How often they rebelled him against him in the wilderness
and grieved him in the desert.
They tested God again and again
and provoked the holy one of Israel.
They did not remember his power
or the day when he redeemed them from the foe.
When he performed his signs in Egypt
and his marbles in the fields of zoon,
he turned their rivers to blood
so they could not drink of their streams.
He sent amongst them swarms of flies,
which devoured them in frogs which destroyed them.
He gave their crops to the destroying locusts
and the fruit of their labor to the locust.
He destroyed their vines with hail
and their sycamores with frost.
He gave over their cattle to the hail
and their flocks to the thunderbolts.
He let loose on them as burning, anger, wrath, indignation
and distress, acomp
of destroying angels.
He made a path for his anger.
He did not spare them from death,
but gave their lives over to the plague.
He struck down every firstborn in Egypt, the first fruits
of the strengths in the tens of ham.
Then he led out his people like sheep
and guided them in the wilderness like a flock.
He led them in safety. Say they were so.
They were not afraid, but the sea
overwhelmed their enemies and
and he brought them to his holy land
to the mountain which his right hand had won.
He drove out nations before them.
He apportioned them for a possession
and settled the tribes of Israel in their tents.
Yet they tested and rebelled against God the most high
and did not keep his testimonies but turned away
and acted treacherous like their fathers.
They twisted like a deceitful bow
for they provoked him to anger with their high places.
They moved him to jealousy with their idols.
When God heard he was full of wrath
and he utterly rejected Israel,
he forsook his dwelling at Shiloh, the tent where he dwelt
among mankind and delivered his power to captivity
his glory to the hand of the foe.
He gave his people over to the sword
and vent his wrath on his heritage.
Fire devoured their young men
and their young women had no marriage song.
Their priest fell by the sword
and their widows made no lamentation.
Then the Lord awoke us from sleep
like a strong man shouting because of wine
and he put his adversaries to route.
He put them to everlasting shame.
He rejected the 10 of Joseph.
He did not choose the tribe of Ephraim,
but he chose the tribe of Judah, Mount Zion, which he loves.
He built his sanctuary like the high heavens like the earth,
which he has founded forever.
He chose David, his servant,
and took him from the sheep folds
from following the nursing use.
He brought him to shepherd Jacob, his people, Israel,
his inheritance with upright heart.
He shepherded them
and guided them with his skillful hand.
Now my first reaction to this psalm is this. It is awesome.
It reminds me sadly of a movie that came out a couple
of years before I was born.
It was directed by an overtop director named Cecil b Demil
and it was called the 10 Commandments.
You know that movie? Now,
back in those days we didn't have 3D HD
gigantic theater screens with surround sound
where the chairs shake along
with the movie like a carnival ride.
But that movie back in that day felt like that.
The whole point of the movie was to overwhelm you
with the grander of it all, the devastation
of the 10 plagues
and Moses parting the Red Sea and brought a picture.
I hope they have it. That's still pretty cool.
Now, after trying to get my heart
to quit palpitating over the epic grandeur of Psalm 78,
my second reaction was this.
How in the world am I going to preach this Psalm
other than reading the passages aloud
and saying, wow, isn't that great?
What could I possibly say?
To me, this psalm seemed like a dramatic poetic summary
of a section of the Bible that covers 400 years
from 1400 BC in the time of Moses
to about a thousand BC in the time of David and asap.
To me it shows what is seems to be a never ending cycle
of God being gracious to his chosen people so
that they are in sweet harmony with him.
Those same people rebelling against God,
them suffering the consequences of their rebellion,
and then God being gracious to them once again,
and that is awe inspiring.
That shows what a patient gracious God our God is.
Praise God. Amen.
But again, what was I gonna say about that
for a 35 minute sermon?
I don't know about you, but sometimes when I first read a
passage of the Bible, I don't think I understand much of it.
I think other people are smarter than me
and they understand more out of a first reading than I do.
But one of the things I have going
for me in my life is curiosity.
If I don't understand something
and I usually don't, I'm driven inside myself
to ask questions about it and find meaning.
So let's go through the first part of this passage
and ask some questions and see what we can learn together.
Verse one, give ear on my people to my teaching.
Incline your ears to the words of my mouth.
I will open my mouth in a parable
asap who lived during the time of King David states that
Psalm 78 is a parable,
but then he goes on for the next 72 verses
and retells a 400 year summary of Israel's history.
But I've never heard of history being a parable before.
I used to study literary stuff back when
I was an English professor.
So I'm pretty sure that a parable is a short, simple,
often fictional story that uses an analogy
or an example to teach a religious lesson.
So my curiosity asked how is 72 verses
of real history supposed to be a parable?
As I read through several Babel commentators, do you know
what I found out where the parable is located in this psalm?
I found out nothing. Nothing at all.
None of them even talked about
where the parable is in this psalm.
So I decided I need to read the psalm again.
In the first eight verses, Asaf asks everyone to listen to
what he's about to say and to tell it to your children
and your children's children.
It's only in verse nine
that he actually starts retelling Israel's history.
The first thing weirdly he writes is this, the mites
armed with a bow turned back on the day of battle.
This seemed to be a strange place for him to start.
If he's telling a 400 year history of Israel,
why does he start near the end
when the 12 tribes are settling into the promised land?
What was so important about the tribe
of Ephraim turning back in the day of battle?
So I researched all the Bible commentators about when in the
Bible, the tribe of e RM went out
to battle and then turned back.
You know what I found? Yeah, nothing, absolutely nothing.
I even found a number of scholars who affirmed
that there's no such event ever recorded in the Bible.
So what is ASAP doing here?
Why does he start with an event that seems
to have never happened, an event that seems to be fictional?
That's when I realized that the tribe
of efm turning back in the face of battle was in fact
the parable of Psalm 78.
I believe that Ephraim turning back from God is
what ASAP uses to teach us as a religious lesson
that explains the next 63 verses.
When I realized that, I thought, okay, now it's a party.
When I preach, I like to start with a big analogy,
often a visual effect
or a prop to explain the thesis of my sermon.
Today, this visual effect is a piece
of art which you can see I think up here on the screen.
Uh, my daughter Dia produced this wonderful piece
of art for this sermon.
It is this image that I believe can help us understand
Asaps parable in Psalm 78.
So let's imagine a world
where there's a locked gate right in front of you.
The lock gate opens and
before you straight up a steep hill is
a stonewalled lane stones on each side.
Imagine that the climb is hard as you go up,
but it is made easier by the fact
that you were walking toward a glorious light
that fills your heart with joy.
Now, imagine that if you turn around
and go down, that the descent is easy
because gravity is pulling you downward.
The bad news is, is that as you are stumbling downward,
the lane gets darker and gloomier.
Two weeks ago, John Wilmuth pointed out in his sermon
that darkness in the Bible often means sin,
evil and even death.
So our analogy today is a stonewalled lane,
and when I preach, I like to have a short, simple thesis
that I state right up front.
So the rest of this sermon makes some sense.
This morning, my thesis is just four words long
and it is this walk in the light
in Psalm 78, ASF starts at the end about a thousand BC
and he goes backward
and he applies his parable to the first 400 years.
I wanna do the same thing
and talk about how this parable applies to us now
as Christians and then later go back
and trace those concepts through Psalm 78.
For decades, I've been telling the community groups
that I teach that all human beings have exactly
one job in life.
You have one priority as we all go through life,
and that is walk in the light.
If you're not a Christian, your one job,
your main priority in life is to walk into the light
for the first time by becoming a Christian.
Right now, everyone who isn't a Christian is locked outside
that gate that leads to the stonewalled lane outside
that gate is deep darkness.
John bunion in his renaissance classic pilgrim's Progress
uses this exact analogy of a locked gate
to the stonewalled lane and leading it up to God.
And I borrowed that analogy
and I've reworked it quite a bit for this sermon.
If you aren't a Christian,
you can't walk up the lane in the light toward God
because all human beings, all of us are born
with a sinful nature called original sin
that makes us rebel against God.
The only way for us to get through that locked gate
and into the light of a personal relationship with God is
to respond to God's call, to let God unlock the gate for us
and for us to walk through the gate
by accepting Jesus Christ as our savior
and as our Lord accepting Jesus Christ
as our savior means to ask Jesus, to forgive us all
of our sins so that he will wash us clean
with the precious blood
that he shed when he died upon the cross, so
that all of our sins past, present,
and future are taken away forever.
Amen. And
that is when we begin entering the gate,
walking uphill to the light
and beginning a sweet personal relationship
with Jesus Christ as an added bonus
entering the gate enables us to go to heaven when we die,
which is a pretty good perk, all in all,
Accepting Jesus as our Lord.
We said savior. Now our Lord means that for the rest
of our lives we make Jesus our authority.
We're dedicating ourselves to do what he wants us to do, go
where he wants us to go.
We are no longer the boss of our lives but Jesus is.
This empowers us to live richer, fuller,
more fulfilled lives on this earth as a kind
of dress rehearsal for heaven.
So now, if you're a Christian, you've accepted Jesus Christ
as you're saving your Lord
and that gate has been unlocked for you,
you are now on the stonewalled lane.
Congratulations, but your one job,
your main priority each day is to walk in the like.
That is to walk in the Holy Spirit.
Those terms are used interchangeably in the Bible.
The Bible says that when anyone becomes a Christian,
the Holy Spirit who is God actually comes to live in
that person and it is the Holy Spirit who infuses us
and inspires us as we walk in the light.
Let's look at a portion of a letter written
by the apostle John who was
by Jesus' side when he was on the cross.
This is one John one, five through nine.
This is the message that we have heard from him
and proclaim to you that God is light
and in him there is no darkness at all.
If we say we have fellowship
with him while we walk in darkness, we lie
and we do not practice the truth.
But if we walk in the light as he is in the light,
we have fellowship with one another
and the blood of Jesus cleanses us from all sin.
If we say we have no sin, we deceive ourselves
and the truth is not in us.
If we confess our sins, he is faithful
and just to forgive us our sins
and de cleanse us from all unrighteousness.
Now many Christians think that once they get
through the gate their job is done.
I'm a Christian, woo woo.
There are a lot of Christians sitting around on the ground
of the lane just inside the gate,
but our job as Christians, once we're inside that gate is
to walk in that light up the hill.
Furthermore, some Christians think
that since they accepted Jesus, their job is now
to try to be good.
Here's the problem. Human beings are not very good at being
good and that includes Christians.
The only way to be good is to walk in the light
and let the Holy Spirit flow through you
and let the Holy Spirit be good through you.
This is the idea of walking in the light.
That's where the joy and the glory of life is.
Walking in the light gives us a lot of immense blessings.
First, it keeps us in that warm glow
of our relationship with Jesus.
As we walk in the light, we go uphill
growing in spiritual maturity over time
and growing in what the apostle Paul calls sanctification,
which means we become more
and more holy walking up the hill as we become more
and more like Christ.
Second, walking in the light produces in us over time.
Great attributes.
What Galatians chapter five calls the fruit singular
of the spirit, love, joy,
peace, patience, kindness, goodness,
faithfulness, gentleness, self-control.
Third, walking. The light also produces in a certain
abilities kind of like superpowers called the gifts
of the Holy Spirit, which flow through us outward
to bless the church and to bless others.
These gifts of the spirit include gifts like teaching,
leadership, faith, wisdom,
healing, miracles and administration just to name a few.
All of these things are great blessings
that come when we walk in the light,
but how do we as Christians walk in the light?
We must place ourselves where God's present abides.
The apostle James, Jesus's brother simply tells us in James
chapter four verse eight, draw near to God
and he will draw near to you.
We draw near to God in part by practicing
what are called this spiritual disciplines.
Now the spiritual disciplines are lifelong practices which
we develop in order to walk into the light,
focusing our eyes upon God.
These spiritual disciplines include things like
praising God, giving thanks to God,
things like Bible study, meditation
and prayer, which is why many Christians start the day out
with a quiet time with God.
Things like worship, like we are doing this hour,
things like fellowship, stewardship and service.
There are many more of these.
Practicing these spiritual disciplines turns our head uphill
so that we can walk in the light closer to God.
But what about the other direction?
What about stumbling downward into the darkness?
Do you know why we all sin?
It's because we like it.
The Bible tells us that even
as Christians we're still affected by original sin, by
what the Bible calls in us, the flesh which can pull us
downward like the weight of gravity on a steep hill.
How does this happen? It's pretty simple.
We are focused upon some other small G God
who is not almighty God, just like the tribe of Ephraim did.
Even as Christians, we still do desire to sin, to do
what we want to do to become our own gods
or to choose some false God
that we think will make us happy.
God's like sexual sin, alcohol, drugs,
or envy, hatred, pride,
and maybe especially in Edmond, money, power or fame.
These and many more are the gods we sometimes worship.
So we try to get out of life what we think we want so much.
Since sin is like gravity pulling us down the hill,
how do we ever have the strength
to go up the hill into the light?
The answer is, is that as we walk more
and more in the light, we find ourselves loving
God more than we like to sin.
The Westminster shorter catechism, which attempts
to capture the essence of all the Bible in just a few words,
states that the purpose of every human life is quote
to glorify God and enjoy him forever.
Sounds a lot like walking in the light.
So walking in the light over times gives us the deepest
fulfillment A human being can have a fulfillment
that we will enjoy even more deeply in heaven.
I love Augustine Bishop of Hippo
who lived in the four hundreds ad he called this fulfillment
of walking into the light.
He called it sovereign joy.
Augustine was obsessed with sexual lust in his life,
but over time he felt like he didn't want to choose
lust anymore because it caused him
to miss out on God's presence in his life
and he wanted that sovereign joy with God
and the way that we're headed can turn on a dime
and it can change many times a day.
You can be driving down the road praying, praising Jesus,
singing Christian songs on K love,
and then suddenly some guy next
to you starts laying on his horn
and you don't even know why he veers in front of you.
Roll down his window and he gives you one
of his fingers like, like maybe this one.
Okay. And suddenly our heads are turned around
and we're stumbling downhill into the darkness of road rage.
I give you that hypothetical, extremely hypothetical example
'cause that's pretty much how I responded to a jerk.
I mean a person about a month ago,
and anger isn't even one of my many weaknesses
when we turned back into the darkness, how far we go down
that hill, that's up to each one of us.
We can ask forgiveness of God, pray
and turn back up the hill toward the light at any time,
but do we, and if so, how long does it take?
So I ask my sermon title to all of us again,
which way are you headed?
Okay, so that's how ASFs parable applies to us here and now.
Let's go back and see how it applies
to Psalm 78, verse nine.
The mites armed
with the bow turned back on the day of battle.
They did not keep God's covenant
but refused to walk according to his law.
So it's not a physical going into battle.
This is a spiritual thing with them.
They forgot his works
and the wonders that he had shown them in
the sight of their father's.
God performed wonders in the land
of Egypt, in the fields of Zoe.
Now we know from this passage that
whenever God was gracious to the tribe of, uh, to Israel
or to Ephraim, that they felt a close connection
uh, with God.
And the text says that they praised him wholeheartedly.
And yet the passage says that they turned back on the day
of battle again, this is a C'S parable.
They turned their heads
and they were walking downhill
into the darkness in their hearts.
What happened next? They did not keep God's covenant
but refuse to walk according to his law.
So they got their head turned around
and then they said, I'm not even going that way again.
I'm going down.
Notice here that Asaf uses the literal metaphor of walking.
Just like in our big picture analogy
of walking the stonewalled lane.
The tribe of Ephraim was refusing
to walk in God's direction.
Then what happens next is they forgot his works
and the wonders he had shown them.
How's that even possible?
How could they forget the Cecil B
to mill over the top miracles
that God had performed for them?
The answer is surprisingly simple.
When we stumble downward into the darkness,
we get a whole lot of spiritually stupid.
The Apostle John speaking specifically of the sin
of hatred writes about what I call this spiritual stupidity.
One John two, whoever says he's in the light
and hates his brother is still in the darkness.
Whoever loves his brother abides in the light
and in him there is no cause for stumbling,
but whoever hates his brother is in the darkness
and walks in the darkness
and does not know where he is going
because the darkness has blinded his eyes.
Let's notice the pattern here.
As it happened to Ephraim, first
they turned their heads the wrong way from the direction
and they were going backwards.
Second, in their downward trek, they deliberately refused
to turn back uphill toward the light
and third in their downward plunge into darkness.
They got a whole lot of spiritually stupid.
Now let's look at the next section of Psalm 78
where it goes back from 1008 BC to 14,
uh hundred bc.
Uh, when the Israelites were wandering in the wilderness
and he applies the parable to them, verse 17,
yet they sin still more against him rebelling against the
most high in the desert.
They tested God in their hearts
by demanding the food they craved.
They spoke against God saying,
can God spread a table in the wilderness?
He struck the rock, so the water ged
out and streams overflowed.
Can he also give bread or provide meat for his people?
What was the cause
of the peoples turning away from God this time?
It was their cravings.
God gave the people a pillar
of cloud casting a long shadow across the desert
to help keep the people cooler by day,
and he gave them a pillar fire
to help keep the people warm in the frigid deserts at night.
Then God struck a rock
and caused water to gush out so that the people had plenty
to drink even in the desert.
And then later God gave them man to eat as verses 23
through 25 state.
Yet he commanded the skies above
and opened the doors of heaven
and he rained down on them manna to eat
and gave them the grain of heaven.
Man ate of the bread of angels.
He sent them food in abundance.
The bread of the angels. God sounds amazing.
I want some, but of all that wasn't enough
for the children of Israel.
In in numbers 11 verses four through six, it says,
now the rabble that was among them had a strong craving,
same word, and the people visual also wept again
and said, oh, that we had meat to eat.
We remember the fish we ate in Egypt that cost nothing,
the cucumbers, the melons, the Lees, the onions
and the garlic, but now our strength is dried up
and there's nothing at all, but there's man not to look at.
They followed their cravings.
What they're saying here doesn't even make sense.
I see at least three problems with it.
One, they remember the menu items available
to them in Egypt, fish, onions and so on.
But do you know what menu item was not available
to them in Egypt?
Manna, manna miraculously falling from heaven thou bread
of the angels.
Second, they remembered that the food in Egypt was free,
but you know what else is free in to them in the desert?
Manna, manna miraculously falling from heaven, the bread
of angels again.
Third, they remember with fondness that the food of Egypt,
it was free, but do you remember why it was free?
Because they were slaves in Egypt
and were never given any money for their labor to pay
for things like food.
So they were beaten by the Egyptian slave masters
and then no doubt given the cheapest food possible.
I don't think the Israelites were eating takeout from Red
Lobster here, and
yet all they can do is complain against the God
that rescued them from slavery
because he doesn't provide as many menu options
as their old vicious slave masters did.
This revolt, this turning back downhill away from God
is absolutely ridiculous.
Do you know what's even more ridiculous?
When I turned my back downhill
for stupider reasons than theirs?
Have you turned back downhill for ridiculous reasons?
In a way, they're all ridiculous.
It's God we're talking about here.
The enduring word Bible commentary points out here
that God promises to provide for our needs.
He never promised to fulfill all of our cravings,
and then after turning their heads downhill
because they wanted a broader menu options, the children
of Israel got a whole lot of even more spiritually stupid.
Can God spread a table in the wilderness?
Can he provide meat for his people?
They asked two heretical words here, can God
these people have seen God work some
of the greatest miracles in human history, miracles
that impress me even on a movie screen,
and now they are textbooks spiritually stupid.
If we wanted a t-shirt message that perfectly captured
spiritual faithlessness
and darkness, all it would need to say across the front
of it is, can God question mark?
Just review some basic theology here.
For newbies, God is all powerful, which is
to say almighty.
He's all seeing. He's all knowing.
He's omnipresent, he's immortal, he's infinite.
He is beyond all space, beyond all time
and beyond all physical matter
because he created all those things
and was outside of them when he created them.
There are some things God will not do, like anything evil,
but regarding his almighty power, there is nothing
God cannot do, period.
What follows is divine punishment.
As human beings, we were designed to be our most fulfilled,
walking in the light uphill toward the presence of God.
We go against our grand design when we had downhill
into the darkness and we suffer for it.
The purpose of every human life is to worship God
and enjoy him forever.
To walk in the light turning away from that purpose,
turning away from that light just brings emptiness,
unfulfillment, damage, sorrow,
sin, evil, and even death.
In the Old Testament, the presence
of God was manifest in a powerful way in the Ark
of the Covenant, remember Raiders of the Lost Ark, okay.
As we have seen, the tribe of eem consistently,
metaphorically walked, downhill away from God,
away from his presence.
On the other hand, the tribe
of Judah consistently walked uphill toward God into the
light because Efram kept turning
away from God.
God removed the Ark of the covenant from the city of Shiloh
and and he had it moved sort of
by the Philistines indirectly to the city
of Jerusalem in Judah, by continually turning back hill,
Ephraim literally lost God's special presence
by walking in the like Jerusalem,
and Judah was blessed by God's presence in the arc
of the covenant, and Jerusalem became the spiritual capital.
Verse 67, he rejected the tent of Joseph.
He did not choose the tribe of Ephrem,
but he chose the tribe of Judah, Mount Zion, which he loves.
He built his sanctuary like the high heavens like the earth,
which he founded forever.
In the next section of Psalm 78, ASAP emphasizes
that God's relationship with his people did not stop
with Moses, but has passed down 400 years
to asaps own time.
By the way, God's presence is always in the here and now,
but he chose the tribe of Judah, Mount Zion, which he loves.
He built his sanctuary like the high heavens,
like the earth, which he has founded forever.
He chose David, his servant,
and took him from the sheep folds from following
the nursing uses.
He brought him to shepherd Jacob, his people, Israel,
his inheritance with upright heart.
He shepherded them and he guided them
with his skillful hand.
If you know the history of King, deputy Noman a number
of times when he turned his head downhill
and stumbled into the darkness just like all of us,
but the grand arc of David's life was that he strived
to turn his head upward
and to walk toward God into the light.
One Samuel 13, 14 states simply
that the Lord sought David out to rule Israel
because David was a man after God's own heart.
Despite his flaws, David is a role model for us,
and yet David the Shepherd was a foreshadowing,
a future prediction of the great shepherd who was to come.
Jesus is our great role model in how to seek God's face,
how to walk in the light.
In fact, Jesus said that he himself is the light.
Pauly Miller, in his book of Praying life states that
Jesus was the most dependent human being who ever lived.
He wrote this because Jesus was absolutely continually
dependent upon God the Father, Jesus always went off
by himself to a quiet place
and took time for the spiritual disciplines.
Even when the crowds were clamoring for his attention,
Jesus was always walking in the light.
God's presence, God's relationship
with His people is always in the here and now.
We stand here in the last week of 2024.
The New Year's holiday is a time for all of us to look back
and to look ahead for each of us.
This can be a time of reflection upon where we are
in our journey with God in this new year.
Let us focus upon walking in the light
of our glorious God who can make us more
and more like Christ over time.
Let us practice the spiritual disciplines,
not in a legalistic way,
but let us look through the spiritual disciplines into
the face of Jesus.
Let us praise and thank our most high loving God.
Let us fellowship with him in Bible study, in meditation,
in prayer, and in the other disciplines.
Let us worship him with our speech and with our singing.
Furthermore, let us tell our children
and their children about how great God is praising
and glorifying his name from one generation to the next
until our Lord Jesus Christ returns in bodily form.
On that great day of his second coming,
my sermon title for this really long psalm was really a
question, which way are you headed?
And my sermon thesis was the answer to that question.
Walk in the light. If you're not a Christian, I said,
the main purpose in your life is to become a Christian
to walk into the light for the first time.
Accept Jesus. We don't do alter calls,
but I'm sure down here at the end we're gonna have pastors,
counselors, elders.
You may want to talk to some Christian that you know,
but you may feel urged to talk about it down here today.
Come down and talk to them about where you are in your life
if you are a Christian, I said,
your main priority in life is to walk in the light,
to walk in the Holy Spirit.
Maybe you wanna come down and talk to counselors
because maybe you've never thought through this before.
Maybe you want prayer. The New
year lies before us.
Whatever troubles we have in our lives,
whatever struggles we're going through,
let us walk in the light together, becoming more
and more like Christ, who is our hope and our forever.
Lord, let's pray together.
Heavenly Father, we pray to you that you would fill us
with your Holy Spirit this morning,
that we would walk in the light.
We pray for those who are not Christians,
that you would pull them to you in a warm hug.
We pray for those of us who are Christians,
that we would be renewed in our spirits seeking your face
giving praise to your name.
Amen.